ce qu'on vit une période où les petits
arabes se prennent de plus en plus pour
des palestiniens et les petits juifs de
plus en plus pour désire acheter un truc
terrible
moi j'ai vécu un truc terrible en avait
salman rushdie et avant salman rushdie
j'avais invité samy naceri samy naceri
m'appelle biais coup de thierry vous
parlez toujours des mêmes
c'est toujours les gens qui sont à
l'olympia les gens qui sont à la télé
les gens soyez gentil parler de la
banlieue et là on fait un combat de boxe
en banlieue une combat de boxe thaï en
banlieue soient les chantiers invités
mois pour parler du combat de boxe au
tac
moi je dis coûtant que mon bon coeur
j'invite samy naceri a qui nous parle de
son combat de boxe thaï et qui restent
assis là arrivent salman rushdie et ils
commencent à s'en prendre à salman
rushdie d'une façon épouvantable
moi j'aurais jamais cru parce que si
j'avais voulu tendre un piège de sa main
je dis j'aurais invité tariq ramadan
j'aurais pas invité samy naceri donc il
s'en prend il s'en prend vraiment à ces
analogies du casse les couilles et tout
est à un moment je dis moi tu t'arrêtes
maintenant quoi ça suffit et il dit oui
moi je supporte pas qu'on touche au
coran qu'on touche aux évangiles on
touche à la bible et judy ben non moi je
suis catholique mais quand les guignols
font prendre de la coke à jean paul 2 ça
me fait pas spécialement plaisir mon
fage l'acceptent parce que c'est ça la
démocratie
c'est ça la laïcité il comprenait pas et
d'un seul coup je me suis retrouvé dans
un monde où un mec me disais que
finalement qu'il faut respecter ou pas
mal sur les relais ce qu'il a dit
j'aurai vingt ans je te descendrait
salman rushdie c est ce que c'est ce
qu'il a dit ça on m'a rapporté ça il a
dit exactement moi j'ai eu un mot
je racontais la vitz maintenant je dis
je disais qu'à un moment il avait eu 2 8
millions de dollars de récompense à qui
la battre et il a dix mois pour 50
balles je te fume ça veut dire ça ça
veut dire non mais ça veut dire ce qui
est terrible c'est que c'est même pas un
intégriste samy naceri qui impose que tu
entends beaucoup d'arabes musulmans qui
te disent moi je suis musulman mais j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] de l'islam je suis pas
religieux c'est pas pratique jamais il
ya des jeux comme wii mais il ya qu un
musulman sur dix qui va à la mosquée
régulièrement moi moi tout où la plupart
mes copains arabes ils font l'islam
quand quelqu'un fait noël ils le font de
temps en temps par respect pour leurs
parents et s'est pas désintégré
simplement sarkozy l'an dernier il
s'adresse aux musulmans de france à la
télé et on en est là parce que parce que
les gamins ils ont pas ils veulent pas
faire de peine à leurs parents donc ils
font comme si respectée en fait tu
respectes pas tant que ça et moi c'est
parce que j'ai eu une nana arabe
récemment elle marchait dans la rue elle
mâcher du chewing gum il ya un arabe
qu'elle connaît pas qu'il aborde et qui
lui dit mais c'est ramadan qu'est ce qui
te prend de mâcher du chewing gum on en
est où la danse est vrai que charlie
hebdo a fait beaucoup plus qu'entre le
pape contre les imams ou contre les
radars parce que si c'était fait part
des musulmans
je suis pas d'accord avec ça les
religions dans charlie hebdo c'est une
des cibles principales
et c'est notre c'est le point sur lequel
il n'ya jamais aucun désaccord
napper sur les religions on est d'accord
ce soit n'importe quel média déficit du
côté des immeubles c'est vrai oui
c'était quand même anticléricaux non
mais pourquoi ils ont des missions athée
mais quand on se frotte pas tellement si
tu sais c'est tout bête on vient de
sortir un bouquin un recueil pendant 13
ans on s'est foutu de la gueule du pape
on a fait un requin gillet le bouquin
ben voilà mais on pourrait
éventuellement faire ça avec les
musulmans s'ils avaient si c'était
autant représenter qu'un pape
aujourd'hui quand tu es catholique
d'être antisémite c'est un péché puisque
jean paul ii nous a expliqués à nous
catholiques que c'était scandaleux et il
est allé demander pardon une synagogue
sur le côté égalité c'est que si on tape
mois sur les imams c'est pas parce que
on n'aime plus les musulmans pas du tout
enfin la religion musulmane je conchie
la religion musulmane comme je conchie
les les chrétiens les juifs et tout le
reste les bouddhistes et tout ce qu'on
peut en inventer encore simplement il ya
des députés qui se réclament de la
religion catholique au parlement mais il
ya le proc le président de la république
va à la messe oui
sarkozy à une messe pour la mort de deux
ouvriers qui sont tombés sur une
passerelle il a fait le signe de croix
est ce qu'il ya un ministre musulman
qu'on a vu ce film est dans une mosquée
est ce qu'il ya des députés qui se
disent mais je n'ai alors là on est
quand même un pays laïc et c'est
peut-être le seul du monde
et quand tu dis le président va à la
messe oui mais le président nous ne
citera jamais le nom de dieu dans un
discours alors que l' écoute les
allemands écouter les américains vivent
les jeunes ont donc de 16 ans nous
sommes en mai cité mais bien sûr moi je
me rends compte de l'importance du hadj
y compris si tenté que j'ai eu à le
comprendre mais j'ai compris la laïcité
en écoutant samy naceri a que 6 c'est à
dire que d'un seul coup le mec qui dit
on ne peut pas tu le mets khadr lui
pense qu'ils les démocrates puisqu'il y
en a pas moi je suis musulman dit il on
n'a pas droit à toucher à l'islam mais
pas non plus aux évangiles est pas non
plus réguler quoi ils se mêlent et la
réponse c'est mais si on peut toucher à
tout évidemment ce qu'il faut expliquer
aux gamins simplement c'est que la
laïcité ce n'est pas l'interdiction des
religions la laïcité ça veut dire la
religion c'est à la maison c'est aussi
con que st est et pourquoi on est
pourquoi on est tellement mal à l'aise
par rapport à l'islam parce qu'on
n'attend qu'une chose c'est
l'autocritique musulmane parce qu'on
sent bien que c'est plus facile de taper
sur le pape quand on est soi-même
catholique oui parce que c'est pas mal
interpréter parce qu'on voit d'où ça
vient parce qu'on voit que le mec en a
chié au catéchisme pour un pull son
enfance
moi quand je me fout de la gueule des
juifs c'est drôle parce qu'on sait très
bien que j'ai pas envie de les envoyer
au four le problème c'est que
l'autocritique musulmane elle vient pas
pour se désolidariser de l'islam
il n'y a pas foule
et musulmans est ce que finalement le
seul vrai combat aujourd'hui il est pas
là quoi est-ce que c'est pas un combat
pour la laïcité simplement bah oui oui
c'est ça des combats c'est le combat de
la laïcité ça notre combat 2009 sans
réplique en touchant bon maintenant on
s'aperçoit qu'on est en plein combat de
la laïcité
frémont a reculé depuis cette époque là
alors que le blé le combat
de convier des autres princes lui et
brillant il ya eu tout bon
ce combat-là devrait gagner on dans le
vrai il donne aurait dû être suivi par
le combat d'extirpation dans le dos
l'esprit religieux
oui mais bon tu peux plus lâche et si
longtemps si les gens reviennent à la
religion c'est quand même voilà ce
qu'ont bien joué c'est qu'on a échoué
sans doute oui mais voilà il ya un taxi
qui me dit un truc très mignon lo'jo qui
m'a dit écoutez monsieur moi je respecte
le coran je fais mes cinq prières par
jour
mais la religion ça vient pas de dieu ça
vient des parents
s'il vous plaît arrêtez catholique je
serais content j'ai trouvé ça vachement
bien poser mais je vais dire en même
temps c'est vrai bah oui mais c'est pas
ça me scandalise la religion c'est un
véhicule un véhicule la religion au site
s était élevée dans une famille
catholique une famille juive ou familles
musulmanes la religion c'est un véhicule
pourtant mené vers dieu peu importe le
véhicule ce qui compte c'est d'aller
vers dieu tu vois c'est là toutes les
religions se valent
moi je moi je pense pas que la région
que les digues sont supérieures la
région de vivre leur religion musulmane
il paraît que scientifiquement les mecs
qui prit tout le temps vivent plus
longtemps a donc là même si ils ont tort
ils vivent plus longtemps t'emmerder
donc c'est normal
enfin même temps les mecs qui boivent
moins vivent plus longtemps aussi donc
je sais pas si c'est bien de vécu
longtemps
oui faute de se mettre d'accord sur la
religion vaches médailles d'or sont pas
perdus le cas des fans un humoriste ne
peut pas et trois mois tu ne peux pas
décrire un mec
c'est vrai on aura encore un endroit où
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus